[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
frosty
the snow oh man right and immediately in
my head
frosty hates hawaii you can't stand it
he would die instantly instantaneously
he'd get off the plane
it would be a puddle it'd be frosty the
puddle just his nose and his eyes he
would be just be dead he hates hawaii
who likes hawaii that's in like but none
of them none of them yeah santa claus
hates hawaii do you think he is over
half the pacific ocean
for 30 kids
how many kids are in hawaii yeah 40 tops
maybe right imagine imagine santa claus
right he thinks it's his last house in
cleveland right right all right all
right it's five in the morning right he
just drops it off and then elf calls him
yeah that's
mass and sentence is like yo yo what i'm
almost done
hawaii oh [ __ ]
got to get in it he probably doesn't
have the presents right he's got he has
to look around what are they like
coconuts
uh coffee here you go kids
santa claus hates hawaii hates him yeah
and i say what do you mean they're like
like how did he come yeah and leanne
looks at me and she's like honey and i
thought she just do it to me because i'm
creative and i was like and i'm quick on
my feet and i was like
wait are you talking about santa and
they're like yeah i go you mean jesus's
brother santa and they're like jesus and
santa were brothers i was like [ __ ] yeah
i go listen after the jews killed jesus
santa was like [ __ ] that i gotta bounce
right so he went up to the north pole
hung out with a bunch of little people
and then they were like santa i don't
want to freak you out but the jews
killed your brother and he's like [ __ ]
that i'm killing all the jews and
they're like no we can't we can't
there's too many saying there's too many
he's like you're right you're right i'm
talking crazy this is what we're gonna
do
on my brother's birthday we're gonna
every kid that didn't kill my brother a
present and that's how we got china and
they're like oh that makes sense
that works out that actually is a really
good story bro i saw a christmas tree
with [ __ ] flamingos all over it bye
hey big tall flamingos all over the
christmas tree you know
don't put things as big as the christmas
tree on the christmas tree you know
christmas tree with the big
some people put big ass presents
in the christmas tree like to hang them
up on there
it looks bad now i'm gonna be honest
with you it looks bad
also
it's never a flamingo christmas okay
sometimes i see things online i saw i
think online said it's a very merry
flamingo christmas guess what it's not
ever a flamingo christmas you want to
start you start
[Music]
city sidewalks you [ __ ] busy
sidewalks you [ __ ] dressed in holiday
style you [ __ ] you
in here there's a feeling of christmas
dickstein donald you [ __ ] you
children laughing people passing dan
after smiling
and on every string connor you hear that
i got
i'm not a great rapper
and i do as many
drop some bars yeah i do as many as i
can myself
and uh
my my my lady helps me and i'll tell you
how bad of a rapper i am i used to for
years for years i used to wrap gifts in
tin foil wow yeah because check it out
no scissors needed no tape needed
interesting shiny
and to be honest to give stay fresh stay
fresh why don't you give me a beat i'll
do a freestyle for you right now all
right
what's up
it's chrissy claus coming at you
at your balls gonna wrap up your gift to
in tinfoil then i'm gonna ask my name
schmoyer i don't usually rap like this
but
uh uh
hold on
hold on we out here
yo
it's your boy chrissy kringle i'm gonna
come and give you some pringles i want
you to mingle but watch out you could
get covered
don't
don't leave the stove it
on
for your mom
get a fake butt
hard to get a ticket hard to get a
ticket to funk master flex them
[Laughter]
so up to the house top the coursers they
flew with the sleigh full of toys and
saint nicholas too
[Music]
this sucks his eyes how they twinkled is
dimpled how mare his dimples how merry
i'm going the stump of a pipe he held
like stop describing him you [ __ ]
would you want to [ __ ] him
his belly so round his [ __ ] like a nub
i couldn't believe it
i wanted to give it a rub
his red little nose i needed to warm it
in my mouth
i sucked on his nose while i jerked his
[ __ ]
stop describing a [ __ ] fat old guy
i gave it a tug
played with his thighs
turned out he liked it i could see by
his eyes
his reindeers watched in wonder
then i [ __ ] sat on the toilet and i
made him give me a blumpkin
[Music]
i [ __ ] while saint nick sucked on my
[ __ ]
then he gave me presents in my mouth
so creepy he's just watching some old
guy the old guys even know it dude
the old guy doesn't even know it you
know
and he's talking about animals they were
tiny
tiny animals with a tiny sleigh
made his [ __ ] look bigger yay
silver bells you [ __ ] you dick stain i
got stolen things
in the city look out for the [ __ ]
taxi cab it's right in front of you you
stupid [ __ ] you oh i'm a ginger i
don't even know anything
you ding-a-ling dick steam donald you
didn't go to the [ __ ] paris accord
with a [ __ ] climate changer good you
[ __ ] pulled out of that and you tell
the [ __ ] u.n where to stick it you
dick sting donald you tell him where
you're gonna be at bry
well i'll be in a appleton wisconsin at
the
stage
almost sold out i'm going to release
some of my special tickets black rifle
coffee bde look at my shoes i'm [ __ ]
crazy
hit a snow crunch see the kids bunch
this is santa's big scene you [ __ ]
sucker you
i'm one day i'm gonna pick up my
daughter this christmas day
and i got 20 dollars
i got toys for that was the easy thing
but now i had to get decorations
so i [ __ ] took like christmas
decorations and duct taped
them to the wall and a bunch of [ __ ]
christmas things and i gotta go get a
tree and i never forget this i went to
the kmart and next to the kmart there
was a tree lot
and as i woke up you know i can't
believe this
there's an envelope and it says
pick a tree and put the money and checks
in the [ __ ] thing i reached my hand
in there
two three hundred dollars who knows
that's how i ate dinner that [ __ ] you
know i went back eight months later
and gave the guy the money best that
ever if you liked this video want to see
more funny comedians we're featuring a
new up and coming comic on our instagram
every single day go check it out right
now lincoln by we're saying everyone
these free stickers look at this he was
chubby and plump
how [ __ ] fetish he is this [ __ ]
he was chubby and plump i came on his
feet
i laughed
a wink of his eye and a twist of his
head right there sounds like he came on
his face
soon gave me to know i had nothing to
dread what
this is getting weird
[Music]
he spoke not a word but went straight to
his work and filled all the stockings
then turned with a jerk i mean that's
actually how it goes
like uh
this sounds honestly like this story
sounds like santa came by had work to do
and gave [ __ ] clement clarke moore a
nice quick [ __ ]
and then was like we're not mentioning
this to anybody and then finished it
giving presents to everybody else
what a gave me presents what a beautiful
favor and then left really quick so he
could [ __ ] the next neighbor silver
silver bells
it's christmas time in the city you [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
railing hear them ring hit him soon
it'll be christmas day you're gonna fall
off the table you fat bastard ivanka's
fine as [ __ ] bro
look at this [ __ ] kid he's trying to
jump through the [ __ ] table and do a
[ __ ] shotgun a [ __ ] beer are you
[ __ ] crazy yeah i'm downing hence
clamp and uh i weighed 11 pounds
i
couldn't make a dent
what i don't get about rudolph can i
just ask what i don't know much about
100 i'll tell you everything you know
thank you so much so um um so rudolph
was being teased
where he was teased and bullied about
having a wrestling red nose right and so
at night probably rudolph went to sleep
crying a lot yeah right he probably
couldn't sleep well because every time
he'd close his eyes the bright shine of
the nose probably woke him up right
right imagine that yeah you're trying to
go to sleep and then also you just see
this red glow in your face all right
terrible that's yeah that's how it is in
my house and my wife he would wake up
and all the other [ __ ] reindeer would
be like you [ __ ] freak yeah look at
your nose you freak yeah and they
probably [ __ ] do what like dogs do
with a [ __ ] uh you know they piss
like this
on his [ __ ] face yep
and then one day it's really snowy out
right the blizzard or some [ __ ] santa
santa is uh he's like scared yeah how am
i gonna navigate
and then he realizes the freak yeah like
his right yeah because a
rudolph the freak you're your head
and like why
right right because if your freak knows
right right
goes okay
and he doesn't and then all of a sudden
everyone likes him and he's cool yeah
that's [ __ ] a [ __ ] story what
they don't tell you is what the next day
they still went back to beating the [ __ ]
out i know they bullied them again
that's what i always think that they
bullied them afterwards of course they
did yeah yeah he got his little moment
in the sun yeah but then after that it
was like that's it let's beat the [ __ ]
out of him because i don't know if you
know but um donner and vixen
before they were in a gang
that sounds like it yeah donner and
vixen were in a game yeah yeah
yeah they were crips they probably had
tattoos on their bellies they were crips
soft little little underbellies
yeah they were crips and they hated that
he was a blood
rudolph was a blood you know he was a
blood from south that's why he was a red
nose
a merry merry christmas to you if you
believe in that stuff if you don't happy
holidays or whatever doesn't really
matter hey i got some news for you man i
know that shit's crazy about the in the
holiday season we always keep hearing
the [ __ ] hey it's not a christmas
tree it's a holiday tree i don't give a
[ __ ] what it is dude call it a holiday
tree what the [ __ ] do i care
who cares
call it a subaru
what's it matter dude it's green and you
hang [ __ ] school bus ornaments on it
you put tensile all over it
who cares there was this one guy who
tweeted
this is not a holiday tree it's a
christmas tree okay okay
okay
all right cool good have a [ __ ] have
have dinner
what do i give a [ __ ]
you call it you call it when someone
gets mad
hey this is a christmas tree oh okay you
mean the holiday tree
imagine being like no no i mean
christmas tree
imagine getting that mad
if i say that's a christmas tree you
mean holiday tree i go like this yeah
one of the funniest things i've ever
seen is one of my boys and i remember we
always go to one of my friend's house
usually on december 26th after christmas
like hang out whatever get together one
of my boys came over once a few years
ago and he was like
just having he was so sad i'm like
what's going on he's like my girl dumped
me and we were like why
for christmas
their first christmas they were dating
for like eight months he gave her the
only gift he gave her was a card that
had a hundred dollars cash in it oh my
god and she got him oh my like
thoughtful embroidered shirts and
sweaters and this he gave her a card
with 100 who is this person and how does
he not know any better she dumped him
he's an idiot
did you what was your reaction to that
when he told you we were on the floor
dying laughing
i was like well you should just give me
a response
yeah he was like he was like but i don't
understand like 100 is like real money
and i was like not to your girlfriend it
isn't oh my god who gives a [ __ ]
you gave her cash cash yeah like he's
like he's donny brosco like he's
freaking donny brosk
a hundred dollars cash it's the most
thoughtless gift you could ever give is
there a more thoughtless gift than just
giving cat maybe
i know that cash is good and you know
especially now with the way the economy
is it's great to you know give people
cash but i want to know is cash the most
thoughtless gift first question
in the song frosty the snowman
what made frosty come to life
all right andrew
um
the uh
the hat and the scarf when she put on
she put on the hat and the nose and the
eyes and the scarf and that made him
come to life anal silk hat correct yeah
baby
boom all right one for one white people
a question
you don't know frosty the snowman
christmas it's all christmas yes
what the [ __ ] do you think this is
and i'll tell you another thing that's
happened is uh birth announcements
okay
i've had several people bring with them
to see me and they will bring the
sonogram of the ultrasound that they had
taken and get you to autograph it or
something no i would hold it up they
would be sitting here and i would hold
it up and we'd be smiling and i would
kind of point at it yeah yeah and people
think you're the dad no no no no they
don't i don't think they think that but
anyway i would look dude if santa was my
dad you know excited
if you'd be like what does your dad do
like uh he works at the bank i'm like oh
my dad santa my dad santa whenever
christmas stories are told you have to
tell them like this
you can't just be like yeah you know it
was a christmas night before christmas
and all [ __ ] game and then all this
[ __ ] happened and the mouse couldn't
even hear a mouse [ __ ] barely this
[ __ ] all you could hear is this and that
and christmas came down and this
[ __ ] happened and then [ __ ] you
heard the bell that christmas they're
really suspicious i couldn't tell you
when this was but you'll see the footage
and they're like we want to get footage
of santa i just got a gopro and and and
they were like can we i see the girls on
the dl set the gopro up on the mirror
by the way this gets really bad wow so
they're gonna bust you so how do you oh
[ __ ]
but they're [ __ ] idiots they don't
even charge the gopro they don't have an
external battery they don't even put a
[ __ ] 128 gigabyte card in it they
didn't even check the card to see if
there was anything like that tricks are
[ __ ] stupid they just put it up there
they're two mouth breathing ninnies and
they just hit record like it like that's
gonna get them i go hold on guys yeah
what are you guys doing and they're like
on the dl they're like nothing i think
are you guys trying to catch santa and
they're like we just want to see if it's
you and mom i go okay i said we'll put
it up there but listen if you're gonna
do that let's get an external battery so
it can run all night and they're like
okay i'm going let's get a big card so
we can record all night and they're like
sweet you're really not santa and i was
like no i'll put it up there and if you
guys check the footage and if presidents
show up they show up whatever
so i put it up there i record right
i leave it
we all we have a few cocktails the girls
go to bed i go to bed i wake up at two
in the morning
and i walk in dogs are laying on the
couch this is i will send you the
footage i will send you the footage this
is perfect priscilla's on the couch i
walk in she lifts her head up puts her
head exactly down in the same place i
walk over to the [ __ ] walk over to
the
mantle i get underneath the mail i have
bells with me and i have a white mitten
and a flashlight i get underneath the
mantel
i jump down so the bells ring right
i flashlight around priscilla sees the
flashlight looks
flash right to mona then i look and i to
the flashlight up to the gopro then i
take the white mitten ver like the white
mitten and i grab the grow pro i turn it
around i turn it around and then i
jingle all around and start messing with
presents and then i go about my way i
gotta go off and i do my thing right but
i leave it in there so smart this next
part christmas dinner we're over my
sisters and with my dad and my mom and
the girls go
dad
upload the gopro village footage let's
see if we got santa and i was like guys
i can guarantee you santa's magic he's
definitely not going to get caught in
this video and they're like dad just
upload it
my dad's like what happened i go these
idiots put a gopro up to see if they can
catch santa my dad's like oh
i think they're going to be surprised at
who they caught and i was like yeah so i
put the footage in and it rolls it rolls
for three out you know from when they
put it down three hours it's three hours
of footage and i go guys you got nothing
you got absolutely nothing and then i'll
like a detective goes scroll to the end
so i scroll to the very end and the
camera's in a different spot they're
like oh the camera's in a different spot
and i go oh my god we gotta scroll and
find the place where it moved i scroll
back i find it and what i had done is i
had spliced me walking out seamlessly i
had cut it out and i just married the
two together
and i
scroll and all you see is darkness
darkness darkness jingle jingle
flashlight glove
flip around and for some reason i don't
know why but when i move the flashlight
around
i mean
the it proves there is a lord in this
world
the flashlight made a shadow that looked
like an elf oh and the girls were like
it's an elf oh my god even my dad's like
you got a video of santa and i'm like
and i'm looking at my dad he's like he
they get up he's like how the [ __ ] did
you do that and i go dad i just edited
the video and he looks at me and goes oh
buddy you're [ __ ] your kids up oh
really i said really and he goes that's
not healthy man [ __ ] what do they
call the hanukkah things
menorah
so we now is it weird that menorah if
you shorten the word it's manure and
that means [ __ ] yes have i always
thought that yes
what came first menorah or menorah duh
no
but i'm pretty sure horses were [ __ ]
for [ __ ] centuries and centuries
why wouldn't why didn't you why weren't
jews like oh boy maybe we should change
it
let's call it a menorah well okay but
that sounds like horseshit
what the hell does it matter who cares
light them up
[Laughter]
what should we call it
poopy candles or menorah well
you can't call it poopy no pooper
candles
why not because it's got poopy in it
menorah it is hey
i remember one year my mother didn't
have a lot of money and
she got us two uh two liter sodas
from
the gas station you know from a phillips
76 or conoco or whatever
and man you think we didn't have any fun
with those boy
all day dude running around shaking them
up and spraying each other
you know and i remember mine was uh
cherry 7 up diet of course my mother was
real adamant about calories
you know and that was some [ __ ] how
you gonna be poor not have anything but
then your mother trying to keep you on
some kind of a diet
jesus christmas
and so but yeah i remember one year we
all got two liter sodas and people's
running around just shaking them up and
spraying each other up and
dousing each other with orange drank and
you know uh
that beautiful
cherry 7 up
and it was fun man so full of soda i
could i you know my belly was just
distended with soda couldn't even keep
none of us could keep our pants on so we
had four children
all under the age of eight
you know and everybody pants all laying
next to them even the baby got their
diaper laying next to him because we
gave her a bunch of soda
you know when you were young and nobody
cared if you filled the baby up with
soda pop have
yourself a merry little christmas
may your days be [ __ ] bright
nobody knows the next line of that you
know
you know everybody knows
everybody merry merry
merry christmas everybody's lead merry
christmas and a happy new year
[Music]
you